I feel bad for T's but they're so
confusing and it's not all my father I
feel like they need to take some
responsibility for my jokes cuz I didn't
come up with this idea on my own this
idea that a person can be born in the
wrong body they have to admit that's
[__] hilarious predicament it's
really [__] funny if it happened to
me laughs wouldn't you that wouldn't be
funny if it happened to me I think would
be what if what if it did what if I was
what if I was Chinese but but born in
this [__] body that's not funny and for
the rest of my life I had to go around
making that face hey clay me
and then we'll get mad stop making that
face that's offensive
what this is how I feel inside
[Music]
because I'm learning Chinese I've seen
you know Chinese I see people's ooh you
gotta learn Chinese they're taking over
Chinese Niihau my racing name Chinese
it's too late it's too late to learn
Chinese it's over
no it's true it's true because it's also
one of the hardest languages in the
world
let me how do you how do you learn
Chinese now as you know they've got over
10,000 characters in the alphabet you
know this 10,000 characters that's we've
got 26 in English and there's still
people going what comes after Q 26 you
know 10,000 they've got that's super
smart oh they must have the worst Sesame
Street in the world we're stuck being a
Muppets in that country I can just see
them on a Monday morning singing to the
kids see so she found him 25 years later
it's our our shoe sorry about this just
horrible and in a mandarin they have you
know when you're speaking English we
have words that we use to stall till we
get to the next word little [__] words
well shove in a sentence words like like
or um or you know but sort of like you
know just little crappy words that were
shoving a sentence till we're thinking
of the next word you know I mean to
stall well Amanda when they have one
word that they love to use and it sounds
really messed up in English but this you
know what I'm saying this is a Chinese
like I know I know I know the word so
you know I'm not making it up right this
is their word all I hear when I'm in
Beijing people talking around me on here
around me is a huge mega
[__]
[__] [__] [__]
[Music]
that's their word now this is a true
story I was at KFC in Beijing cuz I went
to China to eat Kentucky Fried Chicken
right so I'm at KFC in Beijing I'm
standing in line and standing in line in
front of me is a black woman I did not
put her there she was there I swear you
can't make this [__] up so I'm standing
in line there's this black woman
standing in line in front of me the only
black woman in China and she found the
chicken that's all I'm saying all right
that's all I'm saying
I don't make the stereotypes I just see
them so standing in line there's black
women standing in front of me and she's
the Nigerian woman I know she's Nigerian
because she's having a tough time with
the menu and she keeps looking at me I
don't know what to order
look at the menu right and everything
was ok then right so I said you should
try the popcorn cookin so so we're
standing in line right and this little
Chinese kid runs in with his mom and he
runs to the front of the counter right
and he's looking at the menu trying to
figure out what he wants to eat now his
mom standing over there and the Nigerian
woman standing right here and he's
trying to tell his mom what he wants to
eat but he's not really sure so all you
see happening is a [__]
[Music]
[__] and the Nigerian woman looks to me
like I'm supposed to beat the [__] out
of this kid right
why don't you ET here's a straw get him
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
did some shows in China all in Chinese
picked it up with the why it's not that
hard wasn't that complicated you visit
some places you think alright there's a
language barrier but I could get by and
China I was like oh if I got lost I
would die here I wouldn't last a half a
day everyone's looking at me like I'm a
ghost anyway the Chinese were very nice
they were fascinated with my pale blond
children many of them wanted pictures
with my kids they didn't really ask they
just grabbed a kid can I have a picture
with this one I guess you're gonna and
when they were done with the picture
they would rub my blonde kid's head this
you know there are my kids but they're
also lucky objects and after this
happened a couple times I was like hey
we should charge right
China was fascinating and exhausting I
brought my kids to the Great Wall we saw
the terracotta warriors we walked
through the Forbidden City we rode in a
rickshaw and when we were leaving I
asked my five-year-old I said what was
your favorite part of China and he said
I like that time we saw the truck with
the pigs on it because at one point
we're stuck in traffic in this truck
pulled up and it had pigs and cages that
was his favorite part
after the 15 hour flight
and I remember when that truck pulled
out because I remember looking at those
pigs and feeling sorry for them but
those pigs looked happy they were it was
almost like the pigs were looking at me
and my five screaming kids going well
these were not that slaw all around
blacks and whites don't fight so much
you know who don't have no beef with
anybody's Asian people I see how y'all
be doing
y'all just laying the cut off your agent
people beef with other Asian people like
if you call a Korean guy Chinese I've
done this they'll flip out I am Korean I
look Chinese
that's why I said it so accident we
could all train now you all look Chinese
to me it's a mistake I'm not trying to
offend you some people say all black
people look like we don't get bent out
of shape we normally just call those
people police okay just learn to live
with it that's all I can tell